[Música]
el mercado será de verduras hoy en
al horno con arroz con azafrán y jengibre
negro y arroz con azafrán y pasas y
Pasas
tratamos de hacer todo con amor y
con Afecto, la única diferencia es que nosotros
lo va a sacar a la calle pero que hacemos
nos comemos este que es el grande
gran magia
[Música]
para la persona sin hogar es el
única comida que hará
cierto, es por eso que solemos dar la
cenar
cierto porque durante el día cuando son las 8 en punto
en la noche pelea con un amigo que atrapa
un martillo del que quiere sacar la comida
amigo ahi en la noche no todos almuerzan
todos duerman en paz entendido y quieto
tener estos conflictos
[Música]
es una persona que tiene un corazón que no
cabe en su pecho
Sem Peso Sem Medida ¿Pensé que lo haría?
saber a quien su gratitud es siempre un
sonrisa
[Música]